when you had the plane crash would that
have counted as a near-death experience
no the plane crashed we all we all
survived
i i'm the only one who didn't have a
plane crash that was in the plane
because
i can remember everything that day from
landing at um
skyport airport or whatever was in um
in scotts valley and i could remember
going around and having to get around an
obstacle picking up two more passengers
going for i can remember right up to
reaching for the throttle and after that
you press it and i had no memories of
pressing the throttle
and when i studied psychology and memory
i found out that memories have to sit in
your short-term memory for a little
while to get made permanent
and if you get hit
hard in a crash
airplane and car crashes
that very often the memories that hadn't
sat there for 30 seconds are lost they
never get made
so i have no memories of an actual plane
crash and five weeks it was five weeks
had gone by i wouldn't know it i don't
know any time what passed by
and
and i met somebody macintosh somebody i
guess my wife took me down to the
macintosh group and my good friend andy
herzfeld said something about a plane
crash as soon as he said that i said ah
i'm in the plane crash dream when you're
in the in a dream you can turn around
walk the other way and i almost did it
almost did it but i sat there and said
i'll play by the rules of the dream i
talked to him later that night i asked
my fiancee did i have a plane crash or
was it a dream
and she said steve it was a dream
because i joke so much you know i make
up phony stories everybody i had to know
i had a plane crash but i didn't wow and
so she said it was it was a dream i felt
my body in bed i couldn't feel anything
disturbed i didn't feel where i was
missing a tooth for five weeks i didn't
know my dog was in a kennel for five
weeks i would never ever have done that
and then i woke up and all of a sudden
half my brain was now forming memories
and realized they had been stalked
before that in the other half
that caught my interest quite a bit and
then i found a hundred cards on the bed
stand from all the closest people in my
life that had sent me while wishing
after a plane crash i didn't know they
were there but i must have passed them
every day and night getting in and out
of bed they were there and i went looked
at them over and contacted some of the
people now that was a uh
so that was a big deal but i i'm glad
for the plane crash in the end because
it got me to do the music festival right
i asked them because they're
you hear stories about people who have
near-death experiences and when they
come out of it they uh their priorities
are
sort of restructured and
once in a while but um
my personality didn't change right and
not only that but they also talked about
having seen their life go by
one of my psychology professors at
berkeley um you know
was talked about his experience in the
ocean and he had gone under and saw his
life experiences go by and somehow they
saved him
but so that's that so that's probably
real but how would i remember it
i might have gone through it and
remember had all my life flashing before
me but i can't remember it right okay so
um
right so that was uh plane crash i'm
thankful it got me to berkeley it got me
to my degree you know i have a real
degree and i've been made a lot of the
years
yeah rocky raccoon
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
uh